[Music]
in
every game there are mavericks people
who have their own
signature way of doing things ridiculous
oddballs and ingenious
innovators who make us question
everything we know
about the games we love oh my god double
kill
oh my god but there is one player in
competitive cs go
who plays the game in a nearly
unbelievable way chris jay but it's
a hidden underneath that maybe they
should be worried about he split them up
and these pistols are not getting
anything done
kicks them out the server a freak of
nature
who not only plays left-handed but does
so
at an incredibly high sensitivity
mouseport into over-progressing i like
the idea and it nearly pays off with a
kill but this is really where
the lockstick can open up and show us
why he is so feared with the orb it's
against an eco
but nice thought work in the end of 4k
there's the eighth
i'm talking of course about waksick
whose approach to counter-strike is
anything but normal
so why is one of the world's best
playing with this
insane sensitivity and why hasn't it
stopped him from becoming a veritable
superstar
christie's jumping it could be a problem
at least stabilizing charlotte oh
one walk sticks an animal he does not
want to lose
okay so obviously when it comes to mouse
sensitivity
it's all a matter of personal preference
there are plenty of sites devoted to
tracking the way that pro
players play the game their resolution
cross hair settings
and yes sensitivity now we're not going
to bore
you with the math but basically to
standardize a player's sensitivity
these sites typically multiply the
player's mouse dpi by their sensitivity
slider in the cs go menu this new value
is called
edpi or effective dpi
and on those sites we can see that most
of the pro players that we know and love
are all using
edpies somewhere in the mid to high
hundreds
devices had a really rough game flashed
he's gonna get that shot
and that has to feel a little bit good
out middle of the air to take down alex
and now they're pushing
me takes every single one there are
exceptions of course
boomers like forest and hiko who play it
in and around
1600 edpi or hyper talented superstars
like simple and elige
who frag out at roughly 12 to 1300. in
both cases those are generally
considered to be
high-ish sensitivities but at the very
top of the pack
playing recently with an obscene edpi
of 2400 we find osgoor waksick ecker
a turkish opera whose nose like his
mouse
has incredible sensitivity smells bad
i'm sorry about it
a passionate op artist who's
occasionally known for losing is cool
beyond being hilarious walksek isn't
your average pro player either
he's an incredible talent who has found
himself ranked among the best in all of
cs go
when it comes to wielding the big green
and
honestly it is very easy to see why
is he really gonna take this fight
against creek versus zorp and precise
as always an eleventh for walks it get a
crucial opener for mousesports
it was six in a row
beast okay so why play with this
sensitivity at all
well maybe it's because he happens to
play on the world's
tiniest desk i'm not kidding
look at this [ __ ] comedy
but having a good reason doesn't mean
that he still doesn't get
[ __ ] from his fellow players when he's
playing fpl
so the sensitivity is around six or five
for what dpi which dpi 400
for 400 i think 12 or 8. what
[Music]
but even if his unconventional playing
surface explains how he got started
it doesn't completely explain how he
manages to do so well
with such a high sensitivity for that
we wanted an expert meet ron rambo kim
a former world champion cs player turned
coach
who covers aiming mechanics and more on
his youtube channel
he's definitely on the high side of the
spectrum way above average
and for a slower tactical based game
like cs go
it's even more out of the norm because
it is slower paced
the game happens in like a sequential
systematic
way there isn't really need for that
higher sense like in other
arena based games like quake you do have
to do 360s and check your corners
so for him to do that it's it's very
unique but even though the majority of
cs players may be working with a
much lower sensitivity that doesn't
necessarily mean that
one is better than the other and walk
sick is proof
there's definitely some pros and cons of
high sensitivity
with higher sensitivity you do have a
faster range of motion so you're able to
you know point your crosshair from point
a to point b much quicker
so anytime you're caught off guard
you're able to you know make up that
speed
um shave a few milliseconds off from
that aiming but the cons of high
sensitivity is that
because it is more sensitive the
slightest amount of mouse
movement aims the mouse so if you're
nervous
um you know your hands kind of shake it
could get tense there's tension there
your sensitivity is going to feel it so
in spite of all his quirks
how has wakzik actually performed
well his breakout with hellraisers in
2017
put him on everyone's radar and he spent
a year and a half with that team
as basically their talisman fox gonna
back off his angle in one versus three
nine to three is that gonna happen or is
it gonna go to ten because it gets
bombed down
and this awp can start to become a
massive threat
as they do work their way back in
one at a time that awp certainly can be
a threat to any
it's but in 2019
he got an incredible offer to play
alongside
kerrigan and the 16x9 boy himself
as part of mousesports and walksik
didn't waste that chance
he helped mouse secure massive victories
at the esl pro league season 10 finals
and cs go asia championships 2019 where
he was even named the mvp
walksik is the last man he has been a
nightmare for tyloo on the b
bomb side in these clutch situations now
it's the one versus one it's the creek
versus the m4
walk slick is through in the dreams of
tyloo and mousesports goes to the final
now it's no secret that vaccine is a
beast with the op
so i had to know for myself could his
sensitivity actually make
me a better player alright so i need to
switch my mouse dpi
to 1600 and i have to make it 1.5
to attain an edpi of 2400
what the [ __ ] nope how does that not go
how does that go how does this not
nope nope
not even close
how do i where are you
all right all right oh god oh god all
right
anyway growing up no one told today's
pro
players how to use a mouse but whatever
he's doing
seems to be working for him so is it
possible that he's just ahead of the
curve
to find out we consulted garrick forman
a phd candidate at brock university
who works in the neuro-mechanics and
ergonomics lab
garrick explained that there has been a
law to model human movements since we
first started thinking about how we as a
species would go about
using computers it's called fitz's law
and basically what
it says is the difficult difficulty of a
movement is
related to the size of the target you
want to hit as well as the distance you
have to travel to hit it so therefore
performance in this sense is related to
how fast
you can perform that movement so based
on that logic wouldn't a higher
sensitivity be better
you get to the target faster right well
as we've seen
that's not always the case i'm sure
anyone who plays games
realizes that high sensitivity doesn't
instantly make you amazing at everything
there are a number of issues that can
arise from it particularly over aiming i
think everyone's probably fairly
familiar with that
since a small movement at the wrist can
create a large movement on screen
you have to be very careful with how
you're moving when you over aim
you have to correct that or to prevent
over aim
the faster that the mouse is moving the
faster you need to be able to slow it
down
these things all use muscles but the way
that
wakzik plays means that his wrist and
hand
carry a lot of the load if you're using
largely
the wrist and you're not using anything
else 100 of the strain is on that one
joint and all those muscles
because the wrist is built for very fine
movement it's very specific movements
and you need to be very accurate with
what you're doing if you adopt more of a
an arm heavy or shoulder heavy style of
aim you can achieve
most of the gross movements so that
keeps the wrist more in a neutral
position
minimizing risk of carpal tunnel it also
reduces the force that's going through
your wrist
and kind of reduces the risk i think of
overuse injuries for the moment
wakzik's style remains the exception and
not the rule within counter-strike
and fortunately for him it hasn't
hindered him from landing exciting
opportunities to compete at the game's
highest level maybe that's what we love
about players like waksick
he gives us hope that our weird quirks
aren't mistakes
and he shows us that it's possible to
defy conventional wisdom and
still be an incredible competitor i
guess if you have decided to just spend
your entire life focusing on
fingertip aiming then i guess you can
get that good he is just
some just absurd creation that cannot be
replicated in any sense of a human i
didn't even
see where that came from
where on earth has that been all game
long for mouse
and walk sick is on for the ace it's
only jame left on the other side and
boxing
hungry for it delivers all five in this
pistol round for mouse sports
they needed it someone had to provide
and that man is walk sick
one tap one tap one tap one tap
one tap oh one tap
one tap [ __ ] on son
[Music]
oh my god i feel like colin mcneil i
think this is how colin feels all the
time
come on come on come on oh [ __ ]
this